members of the jury i understand you
have a verdict
members of the jury i will now read the
verdicts as they will appear in the
permanent records of the fourth judicial
district
state of minnesota county of hennepin
district court fourth judicial district
state of minnesota plaintiff
versus derrick michael chauvin defendant
verdict
count one court file number 27 cr2012646
we the jury in the above entitled matter
has to count one
unintentional second-degree murder while
committing a felony find the defendant
guilty
this verdict agreed to this 20th day of
april 2021 at 1
44 p.m signed juror 4 person
juror number 19.
same caption verdict count two we the
during the above entitled matter as to
count
two third degree murder perpetrating an
eminently dangerous act find the
defendant guilty
this verdict agreed to this 20th day of
april 2021
at 1 45 pm signed by jury four person
juror number 19. same caption
verdict count three we the jury in the
above entitled matter is to count three
second degree manslaughter culpable
negligence creating an unreasonable risk
find the defendant guilty this verdict
agreed to this 20th day of april 2021
at 1 45 pm jury 4 person019